every day we get out of bed and we ask
ourselves what should I eat to be able
to digest your food comfortably and
efficiently is the essence of being a
healthy human they were very very clear
a healthy diet consists of Dr Anna
Desmond he's a plant-based
gastroenterologist the author of the new
book The plant-based diet Revolution he
incorporates whole plant-based nutrition
treat your problems not just the
symptoms I don't accept that concept
that to build meat you gotta eat meat if
we aren't able to go and enjoy our food
it is such a dreadful impact on our
quality of life the statistics on gut
health are terrible one in 15 to 1 in 20
people in the US develop colorectal
cancer in their life one in ten
Americans have type 2 diabetes that can
reduce your life expectancy by seven
years if you have access to all of these
Foods then choosing plants first is
definitely the way forward